hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast radiomix the potential of
image-based phenotyping for precision
medicine presented by Dr Hugo art we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots for
more information please visit lab
roots.com my name is SF from labroots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is very
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower leftand
corner of your presentation window and
type in your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we can at the end of
the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge this window
just click on the screen icon located at
the lower right hand corner finally if
you have trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the uh top right of the
presentation window or use the green Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem now it's my pleasure to
introduce our speaker Dr Hugo art Dr art
is director of The computational Imaging
and bionformatics laboratory at the
Harvard Dana Farber instit Institute Dr
Arts group focuses on the development
and application of advanced
computational approaches applied to
Medical Imaging data pathology and
genomic data furthermore he is a pi
member of the quantitative Imaging
Network and the informatics technology
for cancer research initiative of the
NIH please join me in welcoming Dr art I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
hello thank you for the introduction um
so indeed my name is Yugo Arts I'm from
uh Harvard uh Dana far Bram and um I'm
the head of a research lab that focuses
on analysis of uh Medical Imaging data
and seeing how this Medical Imaging data
uh can uh potentially have uh a role
also for precision medicine so uh we're
converting Imaging data into
quantitative data that we then can link
to genomic and clinical outcome data all
right so uh this presentation um I want
to discuss uh three I have three main
objectives uh the first one is to
describe the motivation for
computational Imaging and radiomic so
why do we want to do this uh um you know
what what do we think is going to be the
rule for in cancer research uh also will
uh describe a robust methodology so how
we're doing this how we ensure that
these biomarkers that we develop a
robust also across different centers and
institutes um and also I will give you
at the end an example uh some you know
some example studies that we have been
doing in collaborators in radiomics and
imaging genomics just to give you a
flavor of the field all right so uh as
everybody probably knows within cancer
you know cancer is not being here you
know despite the genomic era we see that
cancer as death spur uh in in the
Western World at least stays very stable
so there are several factors of that and
of course now with imun therapy and
targeted therapies uh there's a lot of
breakthroughs that are expected but one
key aspect in cancer that's really um um
uh one of the reasons that cancer is so
difficultly treated um is
inity
so for the people outside of the cancer
field uh a tumor is not a homogeneous
bulk uh it's not a homogeneous disease
you're actually fighting multiple sub
regions within a tumor and each of these
are subclonal regions they call this and
each of these likely will require a
different strategy to uh to cure them so
there's this study that is shown in the
New England Journal of Medicine uh which
I think is really a groundbreaking study
it's already presented a couple years
ago um and this was done by Charlie
Swanson from UCL University College in
London and what they did is in RCC so in
renal cell carcinoma they took uh
patient tumors out and they sequenced uh
different regions from uh from this
tumor so what they found was really
staggering uh is that there's a lot of
shared mutations that occur across these
different regions but also is that
there's a lot of um mutations that are
very unique to one specific subclone so
if there are targeted therapies that are
directed at one of these mutations that
occur only in a specific number of
subclones it's very unlikely the other
subclones will be treated so you could
see for example a treatment effect uh
you know reducing certain subclones
although other subclones that are not
being affected by that mutation are will
not be cured and then will be dominant
uh in the uh a dominant phenotype and
genotype in the future so what they also
did is that they um they look at
prognostic Gene signatures so they look
at the gene expression data from each of
these sub different sub regions and they
um what they found is really amazing is
that they found that for for this the
genes that are in the signature as you
can see in the bottom here and some the
expression levels were even reverse so
this means that if you probe one area of
the tumor the prediction of the
signature was you know this patient is
going to have a great survival and if
you probe the other part of the tumor it
will say the this patient would have a
very bad survival so this really
demonstrated you know one of the key
problems in uh and for Target therapies
but also for biopsy based essays right
if you probe one area you know do you
get a comprehensive view of the tumor
genotype and also you know what what
kind of consequence will this have done
for precision medicine so Imaging in
this um area can really uh bring
complimentary data so Imaging for
precision medicine uh it has a lot of
advantages you know it's performed
noninvasively so you don't have any risk
going in there's some for some like CT
impa there some radiation dose but
that's also low the risks are pretty low
uh and the nce thing also it really
provides a 3D picture of the tumor so
you can really see uh the full cancer um
you know the full 3d cancer in the
complete volume but also what is really
important is that there already
performed in chical practice so there's
a lot of data before treatment uh for
diagnosis and staging and during
treatment for example for radiotherapy
planning and then also for response
assessment so what we can really see is
we can really see a tumor evolving
before before uh during and after
treatment so we can really quantify this
tumor phenotype so we can really can
capture Cancer's appearance over time
and space uh of course there's also
disadvantages you know we proved the can
at a microscopic level not at a
microscopic level what we likely also
want to see uh but also it's often very
qualitative and not quantitative so this
means that the threedimensional pixels
the voxel we call them um the exact
values of these are difficult to compare
between one uh one patient and the other
and even if you have you want to compare
tumor over time the different scans can
have different values so uh we are part
also of the quantitative Imaging network
of the NCI that really tries to drill
down to more quantitative data so that
the the the data becomes more
standardized and also more
quantitative all right so what I show
you here is uh probably the most
important slide in my presentation so
this slide shows the um CT Imaging which
is really the Workhorse and oncology of
six different lung cancer tumors and
what you can see here is that so there
the Imaging is shown in the left and
there's a 3D mesh shown on the right um
and what I want to show you here is that
there's a lot of pheny phenotypic
differences so you know some are very
homogeneous some are very hetrogeneous
other ones are very round and isolated
other tumors are more spiky and
infiltrated into the surrounding tissue
so there's a lot of phenotypic
information that um even non-experts can
quantify from these Imaging data so and
remember that in the clinic for
diagnosis and response assessments uh
only a maxim diameter is use so they
draw a line here and say you know this
tumor is 5 cenm uh discarding all other
information and another tumor that is
like 8 cm and then you know based on
that there will be different diagnosis
and also staging but also response
assessment so there's much more
phenotypic information that is already
presented in these Imaging data uh that
we can um also can extract so our you
know our one of our re uh main reasons
of do what we do is we apply
computational approaches to this Imaging
data and try to extract that
phenotype so um it's really multi-level
data so uh if you go from different Hier
levels you know if you go from the top
you can see that there you know we have
anatomical Imaging like CT um you can
also have like functional Imaging with
dcmri for example you could image you
can image metabolism at a gPad which is
radi labeled glucose um is uh also gives
you metabolism information I can all the
way go down to the genome level which is
also a form of Imaging to say like that
so what we want to do is we want to
convert this Imaging Cube which is you
know not comparable which is not
quantitative and to radiomics data using
uh the approach I will show you later
and once we have that that quantitative
radiomics data we want to link that back
to to genomic data and to clinical
outcome data so what we want to assess
is what are the driving biological
patterns what are the driving biological
Pathways and mutations for example that
drive the disting phenotype and also how
can we use this phenotype data together
with the genomic data uh to better
predict phical
outcome so uh there are two studies I
really want to mention which I think
really set the scene for This research
and
uh one study that was actually published
in nature biotch already in 2007 uh by
Aaron seal and what he did is um he did
very interest interestingly he in in a
liver cancer they Quantified 138 uh
traits by Imaging like you know taxal
hogen Halos internal arteries and expert
Radiologists scor these they say you
know like hogen one to5 or uh is there a
Halo yes no or are there inter um
internal arteries say you know no a
little bit or high for example so they
Quantified these phenotypic trades by
experts then they link that back to
genomic data and they could they found
that um for U several of these um
phenotype semantic features as we call
them we found a very high correlation
with the genomic data and they could
even predict uh 89 or 88% of the genetic
gen so they really showed the
demonstration between a genotype and a
phenotype so the data you know was a
small data set was heavily under sample
for their test it was only 28 samples
for training and 19 for validation but I
think they really you know uh was more
like a proof of principle study where
they tried to combine both data types uh
from the same group they did something
similar in PN in 2008 uh and and this
was done in brain cancer and they
Quantified phenotypic traits like
contrast enhancement and mass effects
which were also again scored by
radiologist and they link them back to
um uh to to genetic b r like each of our
OV expression hypoxia proliferation we
all know that are involved in treatment
resistance so again they demonstrated
this effect between the genotype
phenotype um and GBM cancer in this case
and they had a smaller train data set
for training but a larger data set for
validation all right so we wanted to
build on this so um that's also where
the word radiomics comes from so
radiomics involves the extraction and
Quant quantification of automated
features from images to produce data
elements so we want to automate that
process so we want to use Advanced
features to quantify these these traits
and these Imaging data um and we try to
provide an as comprehensive as possible
quantification of the gum type so we
evaluate hundreds of features and then
using data we drill down to the ones
that we that we see on formative and
then we try to use independent
validation sets to validate the
performance so there are roughly four
steps is a little more complicated but I
think these four steps are the main four
steps that are involved in these
analyses um so first you have Imaging
you know you have to take an image of
course and how you acquire that image is
all the settings and resolution and sign
to nor ratio all these aspects are very
important um once you have you know once
the image is acquired uh you have to
Define segmentation so you have to
Define what is a tum area for example
and what is the normal lungs what is the
hearts um and once you have that when
you have to Define this region of
interest there has to be some feature
extraction so then you extract features
from uh this region of interest that
quantify these phenotypic measures and
once you have these data and you know we
have now 1,600 different features uh the
analysis is very similar to a
bioinformatics analysis you know so you
have to do the feature selection you
have to to drill down to the features
that matter and then you have to
evaluate these respect to other data
types
so each of these steps also has its
challenges um of course uh Imaging data
you know how it's acquired
reconstruction standardization all of
these different aspects are very
important to uh and have to be addressed
for really quantitative uh radiomic data
um so also these segmentations as
described before you know we have to
make we have to ensure that these are
accurate but also we want to automate
them and the main reason we want to
elate them is that uh once we um have
large data sets of say hundreds of
patients we want to go retrospectively
back and analyze these patients um you
know it will take a very long time to
have expert radiologist segment them
manually it often takes years so
automated matters or semi-automated
matters that could help in this whole
process um can be very informative uh
and can really help our um the workflow
of our analysis but also I think even
more importantly is that we want to use
these semi-automated and automated
techniques to really reduce the high
intra and interobserver variability so
if you have five radies that segment the
same tumor all of them will have
slightly different boundaries so we want
to using semi-automated techniques and
automated techniques we really want to
reduce this Observer V variation and
hopefully get more stable results so um
we're uh we're applying a lot of our
techniques in the 3D from the 3D slicer
platform so 3D slicer is a open- source
Imaging platform that's developed here
Brigham um and uh there are several
different uh algorithms of fast semi
automated and automated segmentation
that are developed in there what you can
see here is a visual representation of a
um of of the tumor that is in the uh in
the upper L of the of the lung and you
can really see the threedimensional
segmentation that we perform and also
the long segmentation on the right so uh
once we use these automated techniques
and as one region growing algorithm for
example that is implemented grow cuts um
uh we what we could see is that you know
using this this automated growing region
algorithms you could really find small
extension for example in the phenotype
very small uh so small extensions in in
in the tumor that normally are
completely missed with manual
segmentation so in the top you can see
this automatic one and the bottom you
see the manual one where you can really
clearly see this slice by slice effect
so radiologist segments one slice and
the other and then the other so um and
then never goes often not not goes back
to the to the upper slide so you can
really see that um uh manual
segmentations often don't come for this
full threedimensional thema type all
right so once we have an image we have a
segmentation uh we can extract different
uh features from it so we have to Define
features we have to see if one which
ones are formative which ones are
reproducible which ones are robust um
and uh so we have a current release uh
accounts for 1600 different features and
so what we do is we quantify various
aspects of the phenotype so at the top
you can different see different shape
based features you know which quantify
roundness and spikiness of a tumor for
example and these can be very simple
algorithms um where you calculat the
surface area divided by the volume for
example but this can also be way more
complex where you quantify different
frequency patterns on the surface area
for example um we also have sture
features and um you see these this is by
far the largest group of features that
we assess what we use there is um
different uh algorithms that were
developed in computer vision um and AI
where we quantify different textual
patterns so um the gr level currence
Matrix is a matrix that quantifies say
it simply differences between adjacent
vles it looks more at hogen and the gray
level run run like Matrix looks more at
homogenity so how often is a run length
so how often is a certain value the same
across um across the tumor so you know
you can quantify homogen and hogen
itties um even First Auto statistics can
be important you know like quantifying
aspects like entropy or even range or
Max or median uh density for example
with C Imaging can be very important but
also we transform these images into
another frequency domain and we apply
different filtering techniques like the
wavel filtering and theion of gaan and
we do that um we again can extract
different textual features uh the same
similar textual features that I shown on
the left we can again extract from these
different filters images so all in all
this gives a feature set of over, 1600
uh features at this moment um of course
you know once we have all these features
we have to select the right ones right
and we have to apply different machine
learning techniques to this and we have
to see you know you know which features
matter so um the motivation for this is
you know we we uh if you want to build
accurate and reliable and effic
efficient uh biomarkers radiomic based
biomarkers we really have to uh machine
learning methods and of course romic
really suffers for the curs of
dimensionality so we have a lot of data
for um a limited number of sample often
so there's a need for feature selection
and also we see that that te machine
learning and the more modern feature
selection methods um really uh derive
better um models and if you compare them
to say standard um statistical LS so
what I want to show you here is um is um
this is a very simple correlation heat
map so in both directions in in the
vertical and the horizontal directions
you can see the radiomic features and we
just wanted to see you know how highly
are they correlated and what you can see
immediately is that there a large number
of features that are very high highly
positively or negatively correlated so
that's also um one of the reasons we
really have to reduce this imaginality
so there's a a lot of um redundancy in
data that we have to reduce so um the
nice thing actually is that you know
once we want to reduce this
dimensionality we have access to
different data sets which are not that
common for example in genomics so one
data set uh which I really like and we
use a lot in our analyses is the thewi
test retest and this is a data set that
was developed at Columbia University by
L schwarz's group um and what they did
is they took CT images of 31 non sponson
cancer patients so they acquired a scan
they uh for 31 patients the patient got
off of the table it's called the coffee
break DFT so likely they got a coffee uh
they went back 50 minutes later and they
got another CT scan so what we then did
is we had these two scans available for
the patient uh and then we um we segment
them both and we calculated features so
what we could do by this is is you know
we could say from all the features that
we have if they're not stable within 50
minutes it's going to be very unlikely
that they're going to be informative or
robust so we could remove them uh um and
also you know the ones that are more
stable you know when we don't know if
they are going to be informative but at
least they're stable so by doing by
using such method as this we can really
get rid of uh non robust and non-stable
features um then another way of doing
this we can also apply some machine
learning techniques so one study that's
done by shinton Palmer so he's a machine
learning expert in my group um where he
said ass say different machine learning
methods uh and romics data so we had a
training data of 310 patients and
independent validation cohort from a
different institution of 154 patients
and so from both data sets we extracted
features uh then we did a machine
learning data under training you know we
had different radiomics uh methods that
we evaluated and we linked it back to uh
clinical outcome so just to um to
survival data to see how prognostics
these bomark were and also which methods
works best so once we have defined these
biomarkers only these biomarkers were
applied to the validation data set and
and the performance was assess inment
um and this is actually the main results
um and uh I don't want to show you too
much about the results but just to get a
flavor is so in the horizontal Direction
you can see different machine learning
classification methods and in the
vertical directions you can see um
different feature selection methods and
you know what is really uh interesting
here is that uh you can really see that
certain combinations of classifiers with
which feature selection methods work
really well others don't so often in a
publication you know they choose one and
it's unknown why that was one was chosen
but you know it's it's often very
unlikely have chosen the most optimal
one for this problem so one for example
that we use a lot is mrmr which is
maximum relevance minimum redundancy
feature selection um uh and we try to
use that for example using support
Factor machines or um um other random
Force for example classifiers and we see
that really works well and also now we
are using these Techni as well so
another way of doing it it's also
looking at the stability of these
feature selection methods so we you know
we can assess on the left uh we can
assess the performance for example of
these different feature selection also
stability so how robust are these
against perations of the data how robust
and how often are the the future
selection and classification mod method
how often do they derve to a very stable
result and likely uh a stable result is
also going to be more trans uh
translatable into future clinical
studies so um by doing so you know we we
did these analysis and you can see here
in the gray box for example um there are
feature selection methods which are
really stable and classification methods
which are really stable and there Al
something that's really important
there's always a tradeoff for Optimal
Performance versus stability and often
we have to find a good combination of it
of these which often are not the most
high performance and these in these data
sets we're assessing but at least we
find they're the most stable methods
that we're U that we're finding in in
these these data that'ss we
evaluating um of course we can also do
some Anova we're looking at variant and
what you can see here is that um the
different factors that are important for
example for these classifiers um and we
see for example the classification
method is really important so SE which
classification method you select for
radi analysis is really important the
feature selection method is less
important and the size even is also less
important so by doing these analysis we
can get a good idea you know um what is
you know what what kind of uh
experimental settings affect our
stability of our radi
biomarkers um so if we then go to um so
once we have Imaging data we have
segmentations then we extracted features
and now I want to you know give you some
example analysis that we have done at
Radix and
imaging uh so one study that we
published in 2014 uh this is a study uh
publishing nature Communications where
we did a radiomics analysis in over
1,000 patients with lung or had and neck
cancer uh so what you can see in the
figure you know it was a very similar
setup so we used you know the Imaging
data uh then we did a feature extraction
and then we uh link these radiomic
features together with gene expression
data and clinical data so what our main
aim was to develop and validated
prognostic radiomic signature and also
we wanted to see if we have a prognostic
signature in lung cancer could we apply
that to had and night cancer uh for a
subset of these patients we also had
Geno expression data and we wanted to u
to assess the correlations between the
radonic
data uh so this was one training cohort
that we use of 422 non small lung cancer
patients that were treated at Master
clinic so this is a clinic in the
Netherlands uh and what you can see here
in the vertical direction are the
radiomic features and the horizontal
Direction other the patients and you can
immediately see that there are different
subclusters of patients that have more
or less similar expression patterns for
the features um and Al also if you
define these clusters and Link them back
to uh different like T stage or n stage
or overall stage you could find very
significant correlations uh between
these clinical parameters and also for
example hystology so we saw that there
was differences in Histology for uh
these different features but what you
can also see in the vertical direction
is that um there's a lot of redundancy
in these features right so you see a lot
of features have more or less the same
expression pattern over across these 400
PA so therefore this again shows the the
the importance of reducing this feature
space and what we often see is is that
you know we can quantify say 15 16
distinct traits per cancer type and also
per chronical problem so lung cancer for
example with CT Imaging you know we see
difference say you know somewhere
between 50 and 20 different distinct
trades that we can quantify uh if we go
more often these trade become more
correlated with or combinations of the
other
ones um so what we then did is we uh
also performed a relatively complex
setup where um we defined 440 radiomic
features then we use this test retest
ascribe before to to define a stability
rank so there would did a rank uh for
each feature how less more or less
stable they were then we had also
multiple naations where we uh assess
stability for delineation and we had a
similar stability rank there and then we
had a uh the long run data set which was
the the blue one uh which was a a
training cohort of two 422 patients
where we also have prognostic survival
outcome so using a relatively simple
setup we build a prognostic signature um
incorporating theability ranks and also
developing this based on this long one
cor horse and the signature was based on
statistics energy so the energy of the
of the total 3D Volume shap compactness
so how compact was the shape uh and also
most most importantly uh two uh features
that quantify uh he hog 18 so the gray
level nonuniformity and the wavel gr
level non uniformity and we also found
that these two features really were
driving the signature um U were the most
important in this signature so then once
we had this signature we appli that this
to Independent validation uh cohorts and
we did this both in l cancer so we had
the blue lung two data set uh of 225
patients from an independent Institute
where we could validate the prognostic
performance of this model and U for lung
cancer but also we wanted to see as this
was a CT inter Tuma h8 marker was this
also prognostic and had a neck cancer
patients and we had done two independent
cohorts one from Master clinic and one
from the uh free University of Amsterdam
uh where we had had a neck cancer
patients where we also had um prognostic
information and radi data available and
then we uh used the L three cohorts
which was um a cohort where we had
radiomic features and also gene
expression data to assess the
association with with of the signature
with underlying gene expression patterns
so in total we used over 1,000 patient
fot those
analysis all right I here I want to show
you some um couple of my Ur So what you
can see in black is a training AC of
this signature uh and also in red there
is the validation AFC um and what you
can see clearly is that this performance
the model had a strong performance of U
65 conord index which is similar to an
AC of 65 in the independent validation
data set then we also applied the
signature to the two had NE cancer data
sets and uh we found that the
performance was even higher so the
coners index was around 70 for both data
sets of were independent and we think
that the main reason that um that the
signature perform better and higher in
had NE cancer cor is that because these
uh with lung cancer you always have mov
artifacts from from respiration and a
movement with Haden NE they could fix
dat the he before they take a scan so
therefore it's a likely they're going to
be uh un more less likely there's going
to be movement artifacts so therefore we
think that the signature performs better
but also now trying to uh looking at 4D
information so trying to get rid of
these rep respiration artifacts in lung
cancer and see by doing so if we can
improve this pronostic model online um
also we compared on this vomic signature
and we compared it to different clinical
parameters and we found that the
signature performs significantly better
compared to volume so you know we could
extract more phenotypic information than
just simple volume this is always our
Baseline that we have to assess uh but
also we found that um the combination of
uh volume with sorry of this radiomic
signature with uh TM staging always
showed a significant Improvement in all
data sets so it could really show that
and TM staging of course is the most
important one so we can really show it
here and demonstrate it that there's
more than uh uh that we can capture in
this video infiny data that was
complimentary to the standard clinical
parameters all right so what we then did
is uh so we had this signature which was
developed years ago right so we took
that signature and went to uh Princess
Margaret Hospital in Toronto and we use
over we had a data set access to a data
set of over 500 patients also that had a
n cancer and again there um we got
without going too much in detail we
really showed again that the signature
had a a significantly prognostic
performance and outperformed the
standard Matrix really demonstrating the
robustness of this radionic signature
and uh so we compared it in all the the
complete data set and it was uh it has a
performance of uh 63 and uh then we
removed the the patients that have very
strong artifacts which means you know
dental implants for example they give
they give it large artifacts on the C
images and they if they we remove them
you saw even the performance went up to
65 which was really comparable to our
previous result so here you know we saw
really the uh the reproducibility of the
signature across different um data sets
all right so what we did next is we uh
we investigated for these four features
that were in the signature we want to
see how are they correlated with u
different gene expression patterns and
what we found is is that you know
statistics total energy and shape
compactness they were significantly
associated with some tissue development
Gene sets but most importantly um the
grade level nonuniformity and the
wavelet grade level non uniformity so
really the drivers of the the signature
that Quantified in trenity were very
strongly correlated with cell cycling
and proliferation so this means that you
know if you see a more hetrogeneous
tumor on a CT scan it's very likely you
have an upregulation of sellsy
perforation if it's a more homogeneous
tumor is also likely will have a
downregulation of these poers so we
could also again assess here this this
genotype phenotype interaction all right
so what we done that is we um try to to
um build on these results and to uh
perform a large scale analysis of
Imaging genomics noncancer so we try to
uncover connections between radiomics
data molecular Pathways and clinical
outcomes but also we want to see you
know can we predict the state of a
pathway by radiomics data so can we
predict important Pathways that are uh
that could be potentially important for
precision medicine using this phenotype
uh radiomics data but also we wanted to
assess the prognostic value of combining
radiomics with genomic and clinical
information and see uh if there was
complimentary
information so uh we had two data sets
for this so we had Discovery data set of
262 patients was which were treated at
the muffet cancer center and for each of
these patients uh we had Diagnostic
Imaging June expression data and uh
clinical outcome data available um then
we had an independent validation data
set for patients that were treated with
surgery at the MRI University Medical
Center in the Netherlands and uh for all
of these we also had Diagnostic Imaging
gen expression K and we use this as an
independent validation data set um so we
use a very similar setup you know so in
the top you have an image you do we
perform segmentation we did a feature
extraction and then we did a data
integration where we combined radiomics
data with genomic data and clinical
outcome data so uh so we had data set
one the muffet data set where we had
radiom and genomic data 262 patients and
um we did a gene set enrichment analysis
um using bicr to find um uh to find the
strongest assciation associations
between the radiomic features and the
different Pathways so we wanted to see
which groups of radiomic features were
uh strongly Associated and significantly
associated with groups of bbas data so
what we what were the strongest modules
of these Association modules um once we
had identified these 13 main signals in
the data the main associations in this
data we um validated the Clin these
modules with Association to clinical
data and for the majority of these
patients with 224 patients we had also
clinical outcome data available so we
could really see how are these radiomic
genotype pathway modules associated with
different uh clinical parameters and
then the nice thing is with our
validation cohort we had we could
validate each of these steps in a ban so
we could see you know are indeed these
modules distinct significantly distinct
from from background also in this
independent this independent validation
data set to investigate if you know if
this was really a true signal but also
we could validate and also the clinical
Association um and this is the most
important result that we have shown and
so what these are these are 13 different
um asso Association modules that we are
identified on this data and also
independently validated and the
validation data set uh we were using
robust statistics using with bation to
make sure that you know that was really
the significant from background um and
what you can see here is that um these
romics modules were really associated
with distinct biological processes so
this means that you know certain groups
of romics features were associated for
example with immune Sy system or p53
Pathways other ones were for example the
TG beta or Cadian clock pathway so um
you really show we really demonstrated
that different features quantify
different biological patterns and we
associated with different biological
patterns uh in uh that were discovered
and also independently dat data and also
we found that uh these modules were
significantly associated with distinct
clinical parameters so uh three of the
modules were associated with survival um
five of them with histology and a large
majority 10 of them were were affected
by stage um so one of example is the the
modle number
13 uh which was a an appion of gaan
entropy uh uh features which were uh
significant associated with the
mitochondria and then also another one
was for example the Cadian clock wavelet
textual features where there was a large
uh number of wther features that were
associated with important Pathways that
were involved in the Cadian Club um and
I think the most interesting results
that we found was um where we found the
radiomics um different radiomics also
large panel of radiomics features that
were significantly correlated with
immune system and p53 Pathways and the
nice thing is also we correlated this
back to um to um survival data and we
can find also that this module is really
significantly Gnostic so by doing so we
can again investigate this this triangle
between you know driving biological
Pathways that could drive a radiomic
phenotype and also clinical outcome and
see how this was how these were
associated um then very interestingly
what we did afterwards we uh assess also
you know how are clinical radiomics and
genomics data do they contain for
example complimentary information for to
predict of I um so what we did is we
took two a genomic signature uh that was
developed by another group in 2010 uh
for specific for lung cancer uh which
was 70 genes um to contain only 17 genes
uh for post treatment survival then we
took our radiomic signature that we
developed in 2014 that was never seen in
this data uh and we evaluated the
complimentary effect and um what you can
see here we also buildt a clinical model
which has a very strong performance
which is also known um and then the
genomic um model was performing a little
bit less in uh on its own and the
radiomic performance was also
significantly U performance from
different from from random so we then
did is we com we combined these so we
could really see for example that if you
added radiomics with clinical you had a
slight increase which was also was was
not significant uh but if you for
example combine clinical and genomics it
really went up and but the most
important thing was is that if you
combine clinical data genomic data and
radiomics data um you you had the
highest performance so this was also a
significant difference in independ of
validation data set so really we showed
here the the difference uh the different
complementary value of clinical
radiomics and genomic data and uh to
show the reproducibility of result you
know we also build other signatures and
we use other genomic signatures and
other radiomic signatures that we all
you know we evaluated these all on the
training data set and then went to the
independent validation data set and we
saw a very similar uh um pattern so
combining clinical genomics and radium
xenotype data you know resulted in the
best prognostic signatures in this
case all right so now going to GBM so
brain tumors um you know um what you can
see here is that you know these are
assessed often the uh with MRI data so
the T1 contrast enhancement they assess
it them with the flare Imaging and what
you can see here is again is that um
there is you know several phenotypic
differences that you can immedi spot you
know so you can see for example on the
left you see necrosis so you know some
tumors have you have a large Chun of
necrosis which is a black area in the
tumor and other ones have for example a
very low number of necrotic core for
example which you can see in the bottom
con similarly like contous enhancement
you know some have a very high cont
enhancement other ones have a very low
conscious enhancement edema which is
Quantified by the flare you know you see
some tumors have like almost no edema
other ones are really infiltrated into
the surrounding tissue but large uh um
regions uh but also assessing the tumor
B you can already also see differences
you know some them are homogeneous other
ones are very hog genous so we see again
that there's a lot of phenotypic
differences that are that you can see
they can quantify using amri data in um
uh in brain cancer and we use a setup
and go in detail um but you know we use
a manual slice by slice contouring by
expert radiologist uh and all you know
all these segmented different regions
were were uh approved using a sem
semi-automatic technique um and were
edited and approved by expert neur
Radiology so at the end we're relatively
certain that we have a stable um voltric
measures that we quantify so if we then
look at these volumes we can already
look at the prognostic value um we can
say for example you know our you know
which ones are prognostic and we can see
for example the simple vagic measure
like necrosis you know how how large
it's an aquatic area how large it's in
the confence enhancement area for
example or the Shuma bulk these uh
features are significantly plastic
already to predict overall survival um
other ones weren't for example edema so
the the size of the edema was almost
random which was actually a new result
that be very fun um so uh also we
investigated then you know how what are
the different genomic data so we used 96
patients that were also in the tcga
where we had um also gene expression
data and what we did is we uh we
correlated these with these volumetric
measures now what's very interestingly
what we found is for example that you
know the theosis and tumor bulk
signatures were significantly correlated
with immune response and inflammation
Pathways but other pathways are uh like
uh cell cycling for example were not
significant correlated with these but
were're very
significantly significantly Associated
for example with this edema forume so
you can really see that the volumetric
mega buildup of a tumor um uh really is
associated with distinct phenotypic
processes that each D drive or genotypic
processes that each Drive different
formetric
measures um we also did is we looked at
different mutational data uh again in
almost 80 patients from the tcga we had
also some mutational data available uh
and we found for example the p53
positive uh mutated tumors had
significantly smaller concious andh
volumes for example compared to Wild
type uh and also you know if you we did
this Al on a larger scale we found that
this volumetric buildup of the tumors um
had also U were associated with distinct
phenotypic sorry genotypic mutations so
for example p53 mutations were
significantly associated with um
contrast enhancement and for example The
Aquatic to contance enhancing area which
is a volume ratio was significantly
correlated with egar but not with
example the p53 so you could really see
here that different mutations Drive
distinct formetric um distinct formetric
buildup of these GBM tumors on on all
right um so I think I'm almost done so
this is you know the current status of
radiomic so we really see that Imaging
moves more and more to towards the
computational data science um so uh the
Imaging Community can really learn a lot
also I think from the biomatics
community with sharing of code and
sharing of uh
of data which is almost never done now
in the Imaging Community although the
last couple of years it's getting better
um but also you know due to advances in
imaging you know the scanners get better
the protocols get more standardized you
know now the data that's being generated
in uh in more modern hospitals to say it
uh we can really um qu we can really
extract quantitative data from these
from this Imaging data so that has a
huge uh retrospective and prospective
potential right so we can really mine uh
all these databases that are generated
at uh in the Radiology departments and
we can see we can investigate these
associations um so you know we have
defined a large number of Imaging
features and and others have done the
same um and you know we've implemented
these in Python and matlb and we'll
release a toolbox soon um in was also
Incorporated 3D slicer that includes um
the most important radi features that we
that we found um and also we found that
radiomic signatures are really
prognostic across cancer types now we
see that
there brain cancer and had a neck cancer
lung cancer for example um but also we
see that the RMS or data is really
strongly associated with uh with the
genomic patterns um which really
demonstrat genotype phenotype
interactions um but also we see that you
know we need to really Dr drill down to
robust biomarkers we need to integrate
different data sets large number of data
sets from different institutions to
really uh um drive for bus biomarkers
that potentially eventually could be
used in for precision medicine in the
future
so the challenges that have to be
addressed by the field now is that you
know we have to further optimize Imaging
quality uh we I we only expect that the
performance of these biomarkers will
only go up if the standardization is
better um we have to you know develop
better segmentation algorithms that are
very accurate and robust and uh uh fast
as well so that they can be used by
expert radiologist um but also we have
to define radiomic feature algorithms
that have a high performance and
stability um but what is also very
important is that we have to um see how
radiomics data how these radics
biomarker but the exact rule is going to
be in Precision medicine so you know how
do we improve Diagnostic and prognostic
and predictive power you know this will
be different for each different setting
you know if you want to look for example
at predicting drug response uh you know
you will need in different biomarker and
different uh uh methodology for example
if you want to look at screening data um
but also you know no matter what we do
we need very data set for Discovery and
validation to really drill down to
biomarkers matter that matter and you
know one downside actually challenge is
that there very multidisplinary so we
need for these analysis we need to work
with Radiologists medical oncologists we
work with radiation oncologists computer
scientists with Engineers you know with
medical physicist so it's a very it
always requires a lot of people which is
you know which U uh makes makes it often
L easier um and also there's some
informatics challenges you know we uh
see that a lot of people are developing
different uh code bases uh within their
own laboratory they don't share code or
uh the code is not available not
reproducible um so you don't know
exactly how is feature entropy even
something very simple for this order uh
we see differences you know in different
implementations which means that you
know this uh we have to move more more
to uh to technical developments which
are better
standardized um and also we see that
there's a lot of analyses that are
focused on the single disease side or
Imaging modality and a lot of the
methods and code could Al potential be
us more broader across different Imaging
modalities and different disas all right
so I want to thank you um I want to
thank the people from my lab and from
other people from Dana F briam also want
to thank the people from M clinic in the
Netherlands uh from the muffet Cancer
Center in uh in Florida and from
Princess Margaret Hospital in Toronto so
thank
you well thank you Dr a for that inform
ative presentation it was really really
excellent it's now time for the question
and answer session so if you have a
question you'd like to ask Dr art please
do so now just click on the green QA
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and type in your
question in the box that appears on your
screen and click the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
today so let's get started um the first
question we have comes from Tammy who
asks are there differences in the
surface in tumors that have metastasized
compared to metastatic
tumors uh so yeah so that is actually a
very excellent question oh sorry so I
think that is that is really an
excellent question so um we didn't see
that yet uh although um we found that
there's several shade based features
that were indeed associated with this so
we can see you know like for patients
that were treated curatively that stage
two or three lung cancer for example
that didn't have any disat we found that
certain radi biomarkers were associated
with uh with developing of different
metastases uh in the future um you know
we've we are we still need larger data
sets it was only 150 patients that we
had data on but we're now collecting
data sets we can really drill down and
answer these questions but that is a
very important
question
okay thank you for that um so now while
we're waiting for some more questions to
come in um I'd like to ask a question if
I may if you could comment on the
prospects of I guess radio omix in the
next five years or so what do you think
will happen in the field um as a whole
and what do you have planned for your
lab in this
field um so yeah so so that is a great
question as well so
um I think you know like we we see now
you know that that this data type that
this phenotype data has promised for um
uh within the whole you know cancer
Precision medicine Arena Arena so what
we try to do now is we try we have to
drill down you know to see what really
matters and you know if you for example
you know we seen a excuse me we see now
that we can predict it vitation status
with a high accuracy in lung cancer
patients but um you know we work here
with a lot of medical e colleges at Dana
Farber and it's very unlikely that we
are you know that they will trust a
biomarker unless we have an A say 98%
right because that is like ballpark
where these viy based essays are so uh
the thing is we'll never likely will
never replace biop essays but we could
potentially provide a complimentary role
in Precision medicine as we can monitor
this phenotype for example phenotype
changes over time so if you see for
example that a tumor that was a
diagnosis you know had a low hogen but
during treatment it develops this hogen
uh it can be very interesting to say hey
maybe in this patient which which was
ichor negative before maybe Pro again
because potentially could be E4 positive
at at this at this moment so um the it's
will we have to Define this rule we have
to see how what the rule is um um but I
think also with you know for these
different drug uh for evaluating
different drug response is that you know
what a lot of um
uh draug company C for example is that
they have large data sets and they have
targeted agents for say for example each
of our mated Gene and you see for
example that 90% or 85% of all the
patients that have that mutation that um
are very responsive to the drug
treatment so that's great but also from
the e negative cohort for example they
see that also like 15 or 20% of these
are um um also have very strong also
have a benefit for this treatment so if
for example example the Imaging data the
phenotype data could predict the ones
that each of or negative say you know
also based on inity for example and you
know we can I think it's also even good
for you know for uh to get these drugs
and also potentially could evaluate
these in these patients as well so you
know the different rules that we have to
discover um it's something that requires
a lot of work uh there also very you
know we need very good data set for this
as well the down side is is that often
these data sets and Drug trials for
example were not designed for these
quantitative radiomics analysis so the
data set the data quality itself is
lower than if you you know do the
prospective interest study um so in that
aspect you know we uh we investigating
this and this is also something that
we'll focus on for the next say five to
years that was it was great thank you
for that answer uh next we have a
question from Edwin who asks which
biophotonic tool tools look promising
for This
research
uh so
um um so actually don't completely
understand the question here so the so
certain biophotonic um tools could
potentially be used for the radiomic
analysis so the the big question of
course is always you know what is the
the quality of the data that we can use
so we didn't assess this uh we are um
you know that's something that we're
think also potentially wanted to explore
in the future but the different data
will also be uh the quality of the data
will also be determine if we can do
something uh with it for example you
know if the quality the quality is
relatively low for example in ultrasound
imaging clinical Imaging we see that you
know the radiometer performance uh
doesn't really add anything to uh to uh
the standard clinical parameters uh so
we have to be very careful um what data
what data there is and what data we can
use and also the quality of the data to
assess it and that's uh something that
I'm much certain of uh that's biotonic
tools will be used but it's something
that we are for sure has to be
investigating in the
future okay great next we have a
question from Zev um who's at the New
York College of podiatric Medicine and
he asked have you ever looked at
correlations with imunohistochemistry
data as well as fish and Cy data and do
you find or anticipate added diagnostic
strength with these uh types of
data yes that is also a very interesting
question that is something that we're
actively exploring at the moment so you
want to see you know what is the um what
are the differences what are the you
know what data can we extract for
example from imun chemistry that's you
know look at for example the the buildup
of these cells in different areas and we
can do similar analysis with extracting
different features so we're work here
closely with uh a laboratory from Andy
Beck uh from B Israel um who's also here
in Boston and so we try really to you
know to extract a large number of data
from the uh from the pathology and then
see how we can link that back to the
Imaging data so I expect you know like
it will be very interesting to see how
this different hierarchal levels also
within the Imaging data are calling
you know is Imaging hogen also
correlated with hogen that we see at a
um at a pathology level and also how is
this hogen because we can really drill
down there as well so uh something that
we are um we expect be our hesis that
there will be complimentary value uh we
don't have a lot of proof yet so we're
really actively uh exploring
this
okay thank you okay if there are no more
questions I would like once again thank
Dr Eric for his presentation do you have
any final comments for us before we
go so thank you uh thank you for being
here um please let me know if anybody
wants to learn more about his research
uh just contact me um and yeah thank you
for listening to me for 45
minutes well it was a wonderful
presentation and thank you once again
for joining us today so before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on demand
viewing until November of 2016 you will
receive an email from labroots alerting
you when this webcast is available for
replay and we invite you to share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all we have for now and we hope
to see you again next time
byebye